The fourth of Kruchtens' views is the physical view, and
this is very close to the previous one.
Here however we are concerned with how the processes are allocated
to the various execution units.
And we can use the deployment diagram that we just saw, or
we can use a sequence diagram here.
Here, as a reminder, is a sequence diagram.
The columns correspond to objects,
which could be running on separate processors.
Recall that objects are like classes, except the names are underlined and
there's usually a colon separating the name from the class name.
Going down a column corresponds to the passage of time.
And the lines that cross it indicate messages being sent.
So here we have the, the coordination of three
particular processes dealing with the handling of a transaction.
Collaboration diagrams had the same content as in sequence diagrams, but
they're laid out differently.
Here's the corresponding collaboration diagram for
the previous sequence diagram.
Same objects, same messages.
The numbers indicate the orders in which the messages are sent.